hier c'était plus fin maintenant c'est
moi enfin plus que demain et et
délicieux ton café manche est rien et
puis quel bonheur de le boire face à toi
comme ça chaque matin qu'est-ce que je
laime ce visage n'a pas coiffée pas
maquillée c'est merveilleux bernard
deschamps était toujours optimiste a
toujours content que tout en fait je
réalise que je m'emmerde avec toi tu
vois ce sens que j'aime chez nous c'est
le fait qu'on se dise tout alors pour la
garde alternée de théo j'ai réfléchi
j'ai fait un planning le lundi je le
prends de 10h30 à 14h50 toit de 14h50 à
23h mois de 23h jusqu'à cinq heures
mardi matin
toi de 5 heures à 13 heures 15 mois de
13h15 à 17h45 toit de 17h45 à minuit à
minuit je le prends jusqu'à mercredi
matin 7h30 toi 7h30 11h15 woods 7h30
orange peut pas dire à 8h15 mercredi
mais tu es vraiment le détraqué ce gamin
[Musique]
quand j'étais petit j'étais très
espiègle
ouais pendant les repas de famille
j'allais sous la table et je volais les
chaussures aux gens j'imitais dalida en
mettant les robes de ma mère j'ai adoré
mais des noyaux d'olive dans mes narines
tout ça c'était avant que mon père soit
emportée par un cancer du poumon
[Rires]
ah ouais voilà
moins qu'hier plus que demain ah bah oui
c'est ça